[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
لاوكرانيا وروسيا تحذر من الخطوه
استقالات واقالات لتسعه مسؤولين اوكرانيين
بعضهم حكام مناطق تشهدوا معارك مع روسيا
بسبب الفساد
المحقق العدل في تفجير مرفا بيروت يدعي
على قضاه من بينهم النائب العام التميزي
والنيابه ترفض قراراته
اليونيسكو تخصص اليوم العالمي للتعليم
لنساء افغانستان والنساء في كابول يتظاهرن
من جديد طلبا للتعليم
ايه ده مشاهدينا بولندا وضعت هذا اليوم
المانيا امام امتحان الموافقه على ارسال
دبابات ليفارد اثنان الى اوكرانيا اذا
اعلن مصدر دفاعي الماني انا هولندا طلبت
موافقه برلين على تصدير 04/10 دبابه لو
بارد الى كيف رئيس وزراء بولندا
وسكي قال انه يامل ان ترد المانيا وبسرعه
على طلب تصدير الدبابات كما اشار الى
انوصو ستطلب من الاتحاد الاوروبي دفع ثمن
الدبابات التي سترسلها هولندا لاوكرانيا
الحكومه الالمانيه اكدت انها ستناقش طلب
طلب هولندا لتصدير هذه الدبابات وبسرعه
اللازمه في حين قال وزير الدفاع الالماني
الجديد بوريس فيستوريوس ان حلف الناتو يجب
ان لا يكون طرفا في الحرب باوكرانيا اكد
ان برلين ستكون في المقدمه عندما يتعلق
الامر بمساعده اوكرانيا الوزير الالماني
قال انه لا جديد يذكر فيما يخص تزويد
اوكرانيا بهذه الدبابات الا انه اعلن عن
حزمه جديده من المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 1.3 مليار يورو قائد
الجيش الالماني قال من جهته ان قرار ارسال
الدبابات لاوكرانيا سياسي وليس عسكري
هذا بالنسبه
انه لن ينتصر في ساحه المعركه لذلك يجب ان
نوفر انظمه اثقل واكثر تقدما حتى تكون
القوات الاوكرانيه قادره على سد القوات
الروسيه ليس فقط للبقاء ولكن للفوز
واستعاده الاراضي والانتصابك دوله مستقله
ذات سياده في اوروبا
المساعدات العسكريه والماليه والانسانيه
لاكرانيا ويشمل ذلك انظمه الدفاع الجوي
وهو نظام التصوير بالاشعه تحت الحمراء
عن تسليم انظمه باتريوت المتطوره وعربات
المشاه القتاليه الحديثه
لحل بخصوص هذه الدبابات دبابات لوبارد 2
قد بات قريبا
الالمانيه
وفي نفس الوقت لا يجب ان نقلل من قيمه
روسيا
التينيا
في المرحله المقبله وحلف شمال الاطلسي
يوصل الرساله
المزيد معنا من برلين مراسله العربيه
راغده بهنام اهلا بك راغده الى اي حد هذه
الثقه من قبل الامين العام لحلف الناتو في
انه المانيا ربما تسلم هذه الدبابات في
محلها هل الموقف واضح بالفعل بهذا الاطار
اهلا بك يا ميسوني كان هناك حرص اليوم من
قبل امين عام النيته على ان لا يظهر بانو
نكت انشقاقات بين الاطراف الحنيفه
لاوكرانيا لذلك يعني من هنا كان كلامه
الذي امتدح المساعدات التي قدمتها المانيا
حتى الان وهو ايضا يعني همم يعني
هذا ما حاول ايضا وزير الدفاع الالماني
التشديد عليه عندما قال بانه لا يجب ان
نجعل الان الامر وكانه كله متوقف على هذه
الدبابات لانه المانيا حتى الان قدمت عدد
كبير او يعني قدمت مساعدات عسكريه كثيره
جدا وهي الدوله الثانيه بعد الولايات
المتحده التي قدمت يعني اكثر مساعدات
عسكريه وعدد من هذه المساعدات همم يعني
اسلحه مدرعات مشاهده واسلحه مضاده للطيران
همم وغيرها من هذه الاسلحه وحتى تحدث عن
قيمتها قال بانه المجموعه الاخيره التي
اعلنها من اينشتاين يوم الجمعه الماضي همم
بلغت قيمتها اكثر من ملياردير لذلك هناك
تشديد الان من قبل همم قبل الالم وايضا
يعني من قبلته على ان لا يظهرون بانه
المانيا الان هي التي تعرقل ربما هذه
العمليه التي تريد اوكرانيا يعني شنها
لاستعاده بعض الراغبه ولكن عندما يقال انه
الحديث عن هذه الدبابات سياسي وليس عسكري
ماذا يعني هذا
من دون شك والقرار قرار سياسي يعني القرار
عند المستشار الالماني تحديدا وليس عند
وزاره الدفاع وليس عند الجيش الالماني كان
هناك شركه الاسلحه التي تصنع هذه الدبابات
تحديدا اليوم كانت تقول بانه هي لديها عدد
من الدبابات 130 دبابه تقريبا من الجيل
الاول والجيل الثاني يمكنها ان تجهزها
وترسلها الى اوكرانيا 29 منها اعتقد يمكن
ان تجهزها بحلول ابريل وترسلها لها
والباقي همم يعني بحاجه الى اعاده هي حتى
نهايه العام لذلك من الناحيه العسكريه
السؤال ليس ما اذا كانت هذه الدبابات
متوفره السؤال ما اذا كان المستشار
الالماني سيوافق على ان ترسل هذه الدبابات
الى اوكرانيا التردد والخوف لدى المستشار
من انه هذه الدبابات قد تعتبر ها روسيا
تصعيد تحديدا من طرف المانيا صحيح والرد
الروسي كان واضح وصريح انه مثل هذه الخطوه
ستكون خطيره وبالتالي ماذا نتوقع في
توقعات شو القراءات الموجوده
ما نعرفه بانه هناك ضغوط كثيره يعني ليس
فقط خارجيه على المانيا من الولايات
المتحده من بريطانيا من مختلف الاطراف حتى
الاتحاد الاوروبي بالامس سمعنا بولال
يتحدث عن ذلك ولكن ايضا من الاحزاب
الداخليه هنا في المانيا حتى من الاحزاب
المشاركه ميسون في هذه الحكومه الاحتلافيه
حزب الخضر والبراليين يعني
بيتحدثون بشكل علني جدا ومنطق كثيرا لموقف
المستشار الالماني منهما منهم حتى من
يتهموه بانه يلعب دور بانقسام اوروبا من
هم من يتحدث عن دور المانيا
التاريخيه بسبب يعني تاريخها في اوروبا
لذلك الضغوط من كل الجهات ولكن المستشار
ومساعده يسرون على انه المستشار لن يخضع
الضغوط همم وسيتمهل ويبحث بشكل متلون يعني
كل هذه الاسباب
وما يمكن قد تؤدي اليه يصدر قراره غير
معروف بصراحه همم
المتحدث باسم الحكومي اليوم كان يقول بانه
يعني بحسب ما نقلت عنه درسبيجل التي قالت
بانه حصلت على تاكيد من دوائر حكوميه بانه
المانيا يتلقت الطلب قال بانه الان سيتم
التشاور مع الحلفاء
يقصد بذلك ايضا تحديدا الولايات المتحده
ولكن معروف موقف الولايات المتحده معروف
موقف الحلفاء بانه بطبعهم يريدون من
المانيا ان توافق على ارسال هذه الدبابات
داخل الحزب الاشتراك نفسه هذا الحزب الذي
يعني هو كان من حزب مقرب من روسيا طيب وفي
نقطه الرئيسيه فيما يتعلق بالحديث عن
الولايات المتحده همم كان في اشارات
المانيه انه اذا قدمنا مثل هذه الدبابات
لاوكران على الولايات المتحده ان تفعل نفس
الشيء هل يمكن ان يكون هناك نوع من
التفاوض او هذا الموضوع مغلق بالنهايه
رسميا ميسون ايضا يعني القنوات الرسميه
تنفي ان يكون هناك هكذا مقايضه وزير
الدفاع نفع المبي ذلك متحدث باسم الحكومه
نفع ايضا ذلك ولكن بالفعل هناك كلام على
انه المانيا تريد من الولايات المتحده ان
ترسل دباباتها اولا كانت هناك مصادر
امريكيه تحدثت للصحف امريكيه بانه كل
الحلول التي قدم الحلول البديله التي
قدمناها للحكومه الالمانيه تم رفضها وهذا
امر يعني همم مزعج بالنسبه الينا لانه
يضعنا في موقف صعب وفي موقف يعني من دون
ان يعني من دون ان يكون لنا مهرب منه همم
لذلك ربما هذا الكلام صحيح ولكن لا احد
يعرف من الذي يدور فعلا يعني في هذه
المشاورات وخلف الابواب ولكن هناك نقاش
حقيقي داخل الحزب الاشتراكي تحديدا حول ما
اذا كان سيتم اتخاذ هذه الخطوه التي ربما
تعتبرها روسيا النقطه التي قد يعني تعقد
العلاقه اكثر بكثير مع المانيا من برلين
مراسله العربيه راغده جزيلا لك
في اوكرانيا تستمر الاعقابات والاستقالات
في القياده الاوكرانيه وذلك بعد اعلان
اقاله الحكام الاقليميين لكيف وسومي
وخرسون وايضا زبريجيا وديني برو كما
استقال ايضا نائب وزير التنميه المجتمع
وتطوير الاقاليم
منصبهما كان نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
فيات سلاف شباب لوف قدم استقالته صباح هذا
اليوم ايضا وقبل ساعات اقال زنسكي كاريلو
تيموشنكو من منصب نائب رئيس مكتبي ودونا
توضيح الاسباب هذا ولم تمضي ساعات حتى
اقيلا اوليكسي سيمو من منصب نائب
لاوكرانيا المعلومات
الرئاسي الاوكرانيكسي اريستوفيتش قدم
استقالته ايضا قبل ايام
فساد متجددر في مفاصل الدوله في اوكرانيا
ورثته عن حقبه الاتحاد السوفيتي عماقته
الحرب بما تحمله من فوضى تزيد فرص
الاستغلال تقاطع بين الحرب والفساد فقام
الازمه الاوكرانيه خاصه في المؤسسات
العسكريه
اقالات واستقالات طالت عددا من المسؤولين
الاوكران على خلفيه فضائح فساد
مبالغ فيها شراء منتجات غذائيه للعسكريين
في مكاتب وزاره الدفاع ليست حاله فرديه
المخاوف من شبهات تصل الى نطاق واسع خاصه
في المؤسسه العسكريه لتطرح احتماليه
التحول اوكرانيا الى السوق لتهريب الاسلحه
تلك الاسلحه التي يقدمها الغرب في اطار
المساعدات العسكريه
حمله نجمت عن وعود اطلقها الرئيس لنسكي
منذ ثلاث سنوات يبدو انها تؤتي ثمارها
الان
واتعاهد باتخاذ قرارات رئيسيه بشان القضاء
عليه هذا الاسبوع
في الوزاره تتم على العقود المبرمه
جهود انكب عليها جنسكي للرد على مخاوف
الغرب من سويس استخدام الاسلحه التي ترسل
لاوكرانيا الاستمرار مواجهه روسيا
الفساد هو عامل الثقه الذي سيجذب الحلفاء
الغربيين للاستمرار بتقديم المساعدات
العسكريه واعاده اعمار اوكرانيا التي تلقى
الضربه قاسيه في بنيتها التحتيه خلال اقل
من عام بل هو اكبر من ذلك على المدى
الطويل عضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي مظله امان
تطالب بها اوكرانيا لحمايتها من زحف
البيدق الروس الى عمر العربيه
المزيد معنا من ثياب مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بيك حذيفه بدايه معلومات اوف
حول هذا الملف وهل هذه الاقلات
والاستقالات كلها مرتبطه بملف واحد له
علاقه بالفساد او اكثر من ملف
مساء الخير ميسون في الحقيقه هذه الاقالات
والاستقالات هي مرتبطه اما بالفساد او
بالتقصير في اداء المهام في وقت الحرب ما
يعتبره الرئيس القادم ميرسي هو امر غير
مقبول في هذا التوقيت طبعا الدوله هي
مشغوله الان بحرب ضاريه لذلك لن تتهاون
كما قال مع اي شخص يقصر في اداء مهامه
وينتج عن ذلك اي عمليات فساد وما الى ذلك
طبعا تعلمين ان قانون الاحوال العرفيه
اتاحه عن طريق وصايه البرلمان اتاهلي
الجهاز التنفيذي في الدوله ان يقوم
بعمليات الشراء وان يعني يتغاضى عن كثير
من البروقراطيه وما الى ذلك وهذا طبعا
يشكل عرض خصبه كما قال رئيس نادي
بيراميدزكي وكما قال ايضا رئيس البرلمان
لهضعاف النفوس لاستغلال هذا هذه الظروف
نحن هنا ميسون نتحدث عن ملفين ملف الجيش
هو ملف البنيه التحتيه واعاده الاعمار
يعني الجهتين هي التي تحصل على اموال
كبيره الى وعليها ان تقوم بعمليات شراء
بسرعه كبيره وكذلك ملف البنيه التحتيه
طبعا تعلمين ان اي عمليات قصف تحدث او اي
عمليات دمار تحدث في البنيه التحتيه لابد
من سرعه الصيانه وسرعه الاستعاده نتحدث عن
المدن التي تم استعاده السيطره عليها
والتي دائما عندما ندخلها نرى انها يعني
هنالك دمار كبير وهائل في البنيه التحتيه
فيها لذلك تبدا الوزاره وتبدا الجهات
المعنيه في العمل عليها هنا تكمن القضايا
ومشاكل الفساد طبعا تمت اقاله همم
المسؤوله الرئيسي عن الملفات اعاده
الاعمار بشكل
قضيه او اي ملف مسؤول باعاده الاعمار
الاستعاده المناطق في وكان البنيه التحتيه
الكهربا ما الى ذلك كان هو الشخص المسؤول
عنه طبعا ايضا هنالك قضيه وهي قضيه السفر
الى الخارج هنا التي اثارها نائب المدعي
العام الذي غادر الى دوله اسبانيا في
اجازه طبعا مع عائلته وهذه ال- ال- يعني
هذا الامر كان مرفوض وتعلمين ان اي الرجل
في الان في الدوله الاوكرانيه للخروج من
الدوله يجب ان يحصل على اذن والاذن يكون
فقط في حالات معينه العمل الدراسه
ومهام حكوميه وما الى ذلك هذه هي ال- ال-
ال- التي يمكن من خلال الحصول على هذه
الاذونات اما الخروج للاجازه فهذا امر
مخالف للقوانين لذلك تم اثير هذه القضيه
وتم اقاله نائب المدعي العام
هل البدائل الموثوقه جاهزه لهؤلاء يعني في
اربد او ما في اربد
نعم بالتاكيد هذا شكل ايرباك نحن نتحدث عن
عدد كبير طبعا الان القيادات
قاده الادارات العسكريه في خمسه ولايات تم
اقالتهم كيف العاصمه الذي تم اقالته على
الرغم من ان التسريبات بالامس فقط تحدثت
عن ان الكسيكو ليبا غالبا ما يحل محل همم
في مكتب الرئيس وقد تكون هذه القاله او
الاستقاله هي في الحقيقه وليست اقاله قد
تكون الهدف منها هذا ولكن قد يكون هذا
التسريبات غير صحيحه ولكن نحن نتحدث ايضا
عن اربع ولايات مقاتله ما زالت تجري على
ارضها عمليات عسكريه كبيره واسعه النطاق
سومي الحدوديه مع الاتحاد الروسي وكذلك
زبروزه التي يسيطر الرؤوس على يعني جزء
كبير من هذه النبره وكذلك خرسانه التي نصف
تقريبا هذه الولايه يسيطر ما زال يسيطر
عليها ستكون هنالك مشكله كبيره طبعا الان
لي همم التعويض هؤلاء الاشخاص عن طبعا من
قتلوا في الحادث الاخير في وزاره الداخليه
هذه الاستقالات والاقالات في الشارع
الاوكراني هل تعزز الثقه بزلنسكي اكثر
باعتباره انه نجح في قطع الرؤوس هذه او
انه لا مجزره بهذا الحجم بفتره قصيره جدا
تعني نوع من الفشل
في الحقيقه يعني
انقسام يعتقد ان هؤلاء يعني المسؤولين
الذين يعني قاموا يعني في اتجاه هنالك
قضايا فساد ان هذا تقصير من الرقابه من من
الحكومه نفسها ولكن الاغلبيه تنظر الى ان
الرئيس اتخذ القرارات الصحيحه وانه يجب ان
لا ينظر الى ان هناك اولويه في الحرب وان
الدوله الان في وضع الحرب ويجب ان قطع راس
الفساد مباشره لذلك يعني نرى هنالك تاييد
في الشارع بالنسبه الاكبر من المواطنين
للقرارات التي تم اتخاذها من قبل رئيس
نادي الزمالك مع انه هنالك البعض الذي يرى
انه هنالك تقصير من قبل الدوله وان
الرقابه يجب ان تستمر وخاص رقابه البرلمان
ولا هذه الامور كلها طبعا تم تم ازالتها
بسبب وضع الحرب ووضع الاحوال
في التطورات الميدانيه اشارات وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه الى تدمير دبابه اوكرانيه
وايضا مجموعه من القوات المشاه المرافقه
لها وذلك بعد الكشف عنها من خلال فريق
الاستطلاع الروسي مستخدما طائرات مسيره
بدون طيار الى جانب تنفيذ الاستهداف من
خلال دبات ترمنيتر الروسيه وفقا لوزاره
الدفاع
[موسيقى]
وجه قائد التحقيق في انفجار مرفا بيروت
عام 2020 اتهامات للنائب العام اللبناني
ورئيس الوزراء انا ذاك وايضا مسؤولين كبار
اخرين حاليا
واخرين سابقين على طلب الانفجار استانف
القاضي طارق البيطار التحقيق امس بشكل غير
متوقع بعدما اصيب بحاله من الشلل لاكثر من
عام في ظل عراقيل سياسيه وطعون قانونيه
رفعها كبار المسؤولين الذين كان يفعل
استجوابهم من ابرز الشخصيات التي تم ادعاء
عليها رئيس الوزراء انا ذاك حسان دياب
ووزراء سابقين بتهمه القتل على القصد
الاحتمالي فضلا الى اربعه قضاه ابرزهم
مدعي عام التمييز القادم
اثارت طبعا هذه الخطوه خطوه قاده تحقيق
طارق البيطار غضب من عمل على استدعائهم
فرفض مدعي عام التمييز غسان عويدات قرار
البيطار واصفا اياه بالقاضي المكفوفه يده
امام جلسات لجنه الاداره والعدل وقد شهدت
مشدات بين النواب الذين انقسموا بين مؤيد
ومعارض البيطار على راسهم نائب حركه امل
غازي زعيتر الذي وصف البيطار بالمريض
هو القاضي الذي قفل يده اكثر من 40 مره
عاد بعد غياب تخطى العام اشهر انتفاضته
القضائيه بوجه محاولات جماعيه لعرقلتي سير
العداله
طارق البيطار لنفسه استئناف التحقيقات
انفجار المرفق قبل
بالصدفه
عويدات قرار استدعائه رسميا ضمن لائحه من
ثمانيه اشخاص على راسها ايضا المدير العام
للامن العام اللواء عباس ابراهيم الذي منع
البيطار من استدعائه سابقا
قرار اثلج قلوب اهالي الضحايا بعد ان بحث
حناجرهم مطالبين باستئناف التحقيقات
راي قانوني مخالف ممكن مراجعه المحاكم
المختصه مثل ما حتى هو باراره اثار لهذا
الموضوع انه اليوم المجلس العدلي عنده
الصلاحيه في ابطال او باعتبار ايا تحقيقات
غير بموقع ما لنا بموقع اما المساله
الثانيه لليوم عم تتحرك اكثر هي موقف
النيه بالعامه من مساله خلقت السبيل
بحقوقين بالملف اليوم في خمس اخلاء سبيل
لا يزيل اليوم مصير تنفيذه او عدم تنفيذه
مجهول
على اثرها ازدحمت ارجوك تقصر العدل بحسب
المعلومات بمفيدينا من المده عليهم وعلي
حسن خليل ويوسف
الوزراء المحسوبين على حزب الله هو حركتي
امل
ووصلنا خوف النيه وشارعا شبيه بشارع
السابع من ايار ومخاطر قد يتعرض لها
البيطار تحدثت اوساطه قاضي التحقيق عن
قيامه بما يمليه عليه ضميره وانما يخشى
عليه فقط هو مسار التحقيقات
تعمل
المنطقه
المستمر بالقضاء يتركب الشارع اللبناني
ردود فعل من استدعاهم القضاء في قضيه
احداثها بعد التجميلها لاكثر من عام وصى
مطالبات دوليه بتحقيقا عادل وشفاف غنوا
يتيم العربيه بيروت
المزيد معي من دبي الان في الاستديو
المحاميه اللبنانيه ديان اصاف اهلا بك
ديان اسمحي لي ان ابدا بالدراسه القانونيه
التي على اساسها اعاده البيطار احياء هذا
الملف الى اي حد بالفعل هي قانونيه وطبيعه
هذه الثغره التي وجدتها نعم همم بالحقيقه
هو قرار القاضي بيطار هو قرار جريء همم
ولازم انا بعتبر انه كل الشعب اللبناني
الصف وراء القاضي بيطار هلا جري الموضوع
وقانون هلا بالنسبه
هذا القرار القانوني او لا هو هذا القرار
صحيح من ناحيته الانسانيه 100% لانه مثل
حضرتك هناك
بيروت ناطرين العداله والمحاسبه والحقيقه
انسان
انه ينطر شو هو شو هي نتيجه كلها الدعوه
لسفينه نقول شتت بطريقه هستيريه عليه
باكثر من 40 الدعوه عليه وعلى قضاه مفروض
انه ينظروا
هو اللي طلبات الرعد شايف انه ما في مخرج
همم شايف انه هو امام حائط مسدود وبالتالي
هو الطرد انه يلاقي مخرج قانونه واستند
على دراسه هو اجريها لكن عم يدرسها من
اكثر من شهر وهذه دراسه اذا فينا همم هيك
همم نلخصها بنقطتين اولا هو يعتبر انه ما
في ولا ماده انانيه بتنص على امكانيه رد
المحقق العدل لان هو بنظره لو
المشترع اللبناني كان بيدهنه انه يقدر يرد
المحقق العدل لكن
القانون القاضي اضافه من اجل ملئ الشهور
الثانيه وزير
العدل طبعا بعد موافقه مجلس القضاء الاعلى
وبالتالي هو اعتبر القادر انه هذا انه لا
يمكن لي احد ايقافه السلطه القضائيه
السلطه القضائيه بانها بان همم تنظر بقرار
اداره
تعيين همم المحقق
فجر مفاجاه كبيره باستدعائه للمدعي العام
التمييزي اللي هو نفسه همم بيده قرار
تحريك هذا الملف من عدمه ورفضه اصلا
هو متنحه عن الملف المدعم التمييز بعد ما
عنا تفاصيل همم الادعاء هل هو ادعاء على
اساس انه عارفه للتحقيق او على غير شيء
انما اللي بدي اقوله اليوم القاضي طارق
بيطار قرر انه ما يتوقف امام اي شكليات
اذن همم ملاحقه من هنا او همم يعني حصانه
من هناك قررت في رفض من المدعي العام
التمييزي الى الملف اكثر صحيح
المدعي العام التمييزي هو لازم انه ينفذ
قرارات المحقق العدل ليش لانه اليوم ليس
هناك اي مرجع اعلى رتبه من
القضاء المحقق العدل وبالتالي النيه
بالعام التنزيل تمييز الله يمكن له ان
يعترض على قرار المحقق العدل ولا ان
يستانف قرار المحقق العدل العراقي
يعني متابعه همم العراقيل وعرقله الملف
ولكن امكانيه هذا المدعي العام التمييزي
صحيح
هذا الموضوع وانه هنا في نقطتين اول يعني
طلبات قرار اخلاقه السبيل ممكن انه يبعثها
مباشره
ان ينفذ قرارات اخلاءات السبيل حتى بدون
محاكمه
تمام الخمسه من اصل ال 17 بعد في 12 بعد
ما طلع بحقهم قرار او اخلاق السبيل اما
فيما يتعلق
المذكرات يعني الاستدعاء حتى اذا لن
ينفذها ولا ينفذها المدعم التمييز همم له
حق انه يبلغ لصقه هلا بنشوف قبل ما افوت
لعندك على الاستوديو
قادر على اصدار قرار بتوقفها
صح المفروض انه كمان المراجع الامينيه هي
انه تنفذها لك شيء اذا تصدق
واصدر المذكرات توقيف غيابيه ولم يتم
احضار او جلب المده على العيون فبالتالي
بتصور انه ما بيبقى امام القاضي طارق الا
انه يصدر قراره اتهامي ويخلص بقى منها
القصه وتنحل القضيه الى المجلس العدلي لا
يسال الى المحيط طبعا انت بالبدايه بديتي
تشجع الناس انه يقفوا وراءهم ماذا يعني
هذا التحرك لاهل الضحايا ماذا يعني للبنان
اصلا طبعا لا هذه الضحايا كثير مهم من
جهمه ما ذكرنا من جهه الانسانيه لهم معرفه
مين قتل اولادهم اهلهم اولادهن اصدقاء
كان عمرها 36 سنه ولكن هذا الامر كامنه
مهم جدا لكل اللبنانيين لانه اليوم نحن
على مر عقود من الزمن همم
يعني الجرائم السياسيه بتصير ولا في
مراقبه ولا في حسيب ولا في همم محاسبه ولا
في شيء من هذا النوع ما في ولا سياسي همم
حبس وهو موجود وراء القضبان حان الوقت من
خلال جريمه انفجار انه تجيء يجيء القضاء
اللبناني انه يحكم يحاسب يبين الحقيقه
وانه يتحاسبوا اهم شيء يتحاسبه و تتحقق
العداله كرمال لانه تنعاد الثقه بالقضاء
اللبنانيه لانه بلا الثقه بالقضاء
اللبناني بلا قضاء لبناني قوي قوي
بلا قضاء لبناني او لا يمكن اعاده بناء
المحاميه اللبنانيه شكرا جزيلا لتواجدك
معنا في الاستوديو
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
الداخليه العراقيه تلاحق المضاربين
بالدولار وتلقي القبض على عدد منهم
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه في تصريح خاص
للعربيه قال المتحدث باسمي وزاره الداخليه
العراقيه خالد المحنه الناقوات الامن
بالتعاون مع مفارز خاصه من البنك المركزي
نفذت حملات ضد المكاتب غير الرسميه وغير
القانونيه التي تشتري الدولار بالتسعير
الرسميه وتقوم ببيعه في السوق السوداء
مؤكدا انه تم القاء القبض من قبل مفرز
الجريمه الاقتصاديه على بعض المضاربين
بالدولار
المركزي وبالتعاون مع مديريه مكافحه
الجريمه المنظمه قامت بحملات ضد المكاتب
الغير رسميه وغير قانونيه ضبط هذه المكاتب
وغلقها وايضا بالنسبه للمصار التي تشتري
عمله الدولار بسعر معين من مزاد بيع
العمله في البنك المركزي العراقي وتقوم
ببيعه بسعر اخر يتنافى مع تعليمات البنك
المركزي لذلك هذا الاختلاف يعتبر تجاوز
يعني تم التعامل معه بحزم والقي القبض على
بعض الاشخاص
32 طفلا كانوا معتقلين في مخيمات يحتجز
فيها عناصر متطرفه طبعا تابعه لداعش وذلك
في شمال شرق سوريا علماء اعلنت وزاره
خارجيه فرنسا الوزاره افادت في بيان لها
انه تم تسليم القاصرين الى الاجهزه
المكلفه بمساعده الاطفال وستقدم لهم
متابعه طبيه اجتماعيه مضيفه ان البالغات
سلمنا الى السلطات القضائيه المختصه
المزيد معنا من باريس مراسل العربيه حسين
قنيبر اهلا بك حسين هلا كان تعطينا
بالتفصيل كيفيه تعامل فرنسا مع هذا الملف
نعم ميسون في الواقع فرنسا كانت في
السنوات الماضيه تقول انها لن تتعامل الا
مع كل حاله على حدا ولن تستعيدها الاطفال
والنساء بشكل جماعي لكنها ومنذ بضعه اشهر
فقط بدات تغير سياستها لنقل منذ اقل من
عام بدات تغير سياستها في هذا المجال
وبدات تستقدم دفعات متزايده العدد من
الاطفال والنساء من افراد عائلات عناصر
داعش الذين كانوا موجودين ومازال بعضهم
موجوده في شمال شرق سوريا كانت هناك دفعه
كبيره في شهر تموز يوليو الماضي ثم في
تشرين الاول اكتوبر وهذه الدفعه الثالثه
الكبيره اليوم فرنسا تتعامل مع هذا الملف
على اساس مخاوف معينه لذلك لم تكن تفتح
الباب على مصر عليه
[موسيقى]
المخاوف فلماذا هذا الحذر من قبل فرنسا في
التعاطي مع هذا الملف
امنيه فرنسا تعتبر ان هؤلاء القصر نشاوا
في بيئه لديها الثقافه تشجع على التطرف
تقصد بيئه عناصر داعش وبالتالي فان هؤلاء
حتى لو كانوا قصرا اليوم فانه قد يسهل
استخدامهم امنيا في المستقبل للقيام بها
جمال في فرنسا في المستقبل ولكن طبعا
السبت الماضي هناك لجنه امميه وجهت لهما
كبيرا الى فرنسا في هذا الموضوع بعد ان
كانت ايضا محكمه همم حقوق الانسان
الاوروبيه واجهت اليها لوما ممثلا ميسون
باساسه هو الذي ضغط على فرنسا لتغيير
سياسهها هذا ما افهمه
تماما يوم السبت الماضي يعتبر لجنه مناهضه
التعذيب في الامم المتحده ان فرنسا لا
تقوم بواجبها لناحيه احترامه منصه عليه
معاهده مناهضه التعذيب التي وقعت عليها
فرنسا والتي تلزم في بنديها الثاني
والسادس عشر كل بلد وقع على المعاهده بان
يحمي الذين يتعرضون لعمليات التعذيب جاء
ذلك بعد ان تقدمت عائلات من بين عائلات
التي يتواجد افراد منها في سوريا تقدم
بالتماس الى هذه اللجنه الامميه واتهمت
محاميه بعض العائلات فرنسا بانها تركت
اطفال
وامهاتهم لمصيرهم في منطقه حرب فردت فرنسا
ان المعاهده التي وقعت عليها لا تلزمها في
حمايه الذين يتعرضون
للتعذيب في منطقه لا تسيطر عليها السلطات
القضائيه الفرنسيه ثم كان هناك رد على
الرد فرنسيه وجهت عائلات عناصر داعش عبر
محاميه لاحدى هذه العائلات كلاما الى
سلطات الفرنسيه تعتبر ان فرنسا حتى لو لم
تكن لديها سلطه قضائيه في البدل البلد
الذي يتعرض لدي الذي يتعرض فيها هؤلاء
للتعذيب لكن عليها ان تقوم بما يجب ان
تقوم به لحمايتهم من الانتهاكات الخطيره
لحقوق الانسان
وتحديدا لتجنيبهم المعامله المهمه وغير
الانسانيه هذا خامس شتاء يقضيه اطفال
ونساء فرنسيون في ظروف صعبه تقول محاميه
احدى هذه العائلات الفرنسيين الموجودين في
شمال شرق سوريا بالمناسبه الخارجيه
الفرنسيه ومن مقرها الذي يبدو خلفي صدر
عنها بيان صباح اليوم شكر الاداره المحليه
في شمال شرق سوريا التي سمح تعاونها
باجلاء هذه الدفعه الجديده من العائله من
سوريا الى فرنسا المقصود هنا ميسون
الاداره الكرديه مراسل العربيه
الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
دعوتان قضائيتان ضد تويتر في سان
فرانسيسكو ولندن بسبب عدم دفع ايجار
المقرات
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه تظاهرات نساء
طالبان اليوم مع اليوم الدولي للتعليم
الذي يوافق الرابع والعشرين من يناير من
كل عام رفضت المتظاهرات الحضر التعليم
عليهن الذي تفرزه طالبان في افغانستان
واكدنا على ان حركه طالبان حرمتهن من حق
التعليم والمعرفه ويذكر ان اليوم الدوري
للتعليم هذا العام خصصته اليمنى
لافغانستان تضامنا مع النساء اللاتي حرمنا
من حق التعليم
دعاء امين عام الامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيرف في اليوم العالمي للتعليم دعا
طالبان الى التراجع عن قرارها بشان تقييد
ومنع التعليم للفتيات في افغانستان وقال
جوزيرس ان الوقت قد حان لانهاء كافه
القوانين التي تعيق الوصول الى التعليم
من جهتي اشار مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق
الشؤون الانسانيه في افغانستان الى ان
حركه طالبان منعت اكثر من مليون فتاه من
الالتحاق بالمدارس منعت اكثر من 100,000
فتاه من التعليم الجامعي شدد المكتب على
اهميه هذه القرارات
المزيد معنا من باريس صدف رحيم الصحفيه
الافغانيه اهلا بك صدف من خلال متابعتك
الى التحركات في الداخل الافغاني طبعا
والذي يتعلق بتحرك المراه الافغانيه هناك
في هذا اليوم تحديدا ماذا تقولين
انترناف
العالمي للتعليم
وتعيشه دول مختلفه تحتفي فيه
باهميه التعليم
وخاصه الشعب في العالم لكن في افغانستان
صوره مختلفه حتى شخص واحد في افغانستان لا
يمتلكوا حق ان يذهب للجامعه فهذه المشكله
للشعب الافغاني وفي كثير من المرات كانت
طالبان
تسعى لتسكير كافه ابواب جامعه منعا للشباب
والنساء من التعليم والنساء يرون على مراه
العالم بان هذه قد تكون حجره
عائقا امام مستقبل الهند وانا لست متفائله
صراحه في المستقبل والنظرا لهذا الامر
خلاص دي بالنسبه الي مليونين شخص سوف
يعيشون هذه الحاله التي لا يتمتعون فيها
بالتعليم كيف لنا ان نشعر بالتفاؤل في مثل
هذه الظروف وهناك فارق كبير نراه بين
افغانستان ودول اخرى
من حيث النشاط الشعبي ففي افغانستان مثلا
هناك اناس كثر من المتعلمين ومن رجال
الاعمال الذين تخرجوا من الجامعات في
السابق الان لم يعد هناك اي حق لي الناس
اللي لاستخدام قدراتهم
ومعرفتهم بسبب وجود طالبا وفي دول اخرى
الصوره المختلفه رغم انهم
يستفيدون من من هؤلاء المتعلمين في هذا
الامر معدوم في افغان سنه هل لنا ان نفكر
في افغانستان بطريقه مختلفه بالنسبه
محرومين من حق الوصول الى التعليم او
العمل او اي حقوق بسيطه اخرى كيف لنا ان
نتفائل بالمستقبل هذا البلد بالنسبه
للطالبه فهي ما ترغب به هو هو
ان
تكون لديهم حكومه
تعزلوا شعبها فهذا لا يبعث ابدا على اي
تفاعل وخاصه بالنسبه للتعلم والثقافه
لكافه النساء في افغانستان صدف انت غير
متفائله ولكن هناك نساء خرجت في الشارع
اليوم الا تعولين على مثل هذا الحراك
وماذا عن المجتمع الدولي
اباوت بروتس اوف افغان
النساء
قد تكون هذه اخبار جيده بالنسبه للشعب
الافغاني لانه اذا ما كان الشعب الافغاني
والنساء قد صفوا في ما بينهم فان حكومه
طالبا لن تقطع مكتوفه الايدين
وفي اوقات مختلفه كانت النساء تعاني في
افغانستان
اه الارض
التي يفرضها حكم طالبان
والان
وبسبب اغلاق ابواب الجامعات وابواب
التعليم
والمعاناه التي يعيشها الشعب هذا الامر لا
يعد كافيا لاننا لا نتحدث سوا عن مجموعه
من الاشخاص الذين يقومون بتغيير البلاد
هذا امر غير مقبول
اننا بحاجه لمساعدتي النساء والشعب
الافغانيين ولابد للمجتمع الدولي ان يقف
الى جانب المراه الافغانيه فهناك مجموعه
من النساء اللواتي يتم احتجاجهن من قبل
طالبا وهذا يشكل معاناه كبيره وهي مجرد
مطالبات بحقوق اساسيه بالتعليم والمعرفه
[موسيقى]
همم
التي تواجه المراه الافغانيه
بانها ما تزال تعيش دون ان تحظى باي دعم
اساسي لحقوقها الاساسيه وهناك مجموعات
كبيره من الرجال التي
تمسك بزمام الامور وتحرم المراه من كافه
هذه تحرمها من هذه الحقوق اذا ما كنا نسعى
لتغيير الوضع فانه من الضروره ان نعمل على
حشد الدعم للنساء ومن قبل الاسره الدوليه
لتنظر الى حجم المعاناه التي تعيشها
المراه بالنسبه للتعليم وحق العمل
لابد لنا ان لا يغيب عن انظارنا ايضا ما
تقوم به طالبان وخاصه في الاونه الاخيره
من حيث القوانين التي فرضتها فهناك اسر
كثيره تعد مسؤوله عن
افرادها واطفالها فعلى مر سنوات طويله وما
خلال معاشته افغانستان فلم تعد هذه الاسر
قادره على ان تسد به احتياجات اسرها ومن
مضطر النساء
لضيق الوقت صدف رحيمي الصحفيه الافغانيه
عذرا اسمحي لي شكرا جزيلا لك
متاعب قضائيه جديده تتعرض لها شركه وتر
هذه المره بسبب نزاعم حول ايجارات غير
مدفوعه لمقرين تابعين للشركه القضيه
الاولى مرفوعه في سان فرانسيسكو من قبل
الشركه المالكه للعقار حيث تطالب الشركه
بحوالي 3 ملايين 400 الف دولار اما في
بريطانيا فقد رفعت شركه كراون ستيت
المسؤوله عن اداره املاك التاج البريطاني
ضد تويتر مطالبه بسداد الايجارات المتاخره
عن قرن تستاجره تويتر في وسط لندن
في اخر ظهور لها كراسه وزراء نيوزيلندا
قالت جاسنده اردن ان اكثر ما ستفتقده هم
الناس لانهم كانوا مصدر المتعه في عملها
على حد وصفها وكانت الوزيره التي تعتبر
رمزا عالميا لليسار قد صدمت مؤيديها
باعلامها الاستقاله من رئاسه الوزراء بعد
اكثر من خمس سنوات من تولى المنصب لافته
الى انها لم تعد لديها القدره على
الاستمرار
قالت الامم المتحده كورونا ادت الى انخفاض
ضحايا الاتجار بالبشر لان مستوى منذ 20
عاما تقرير الامم المتحده اوضح ان العدد
انخفض بنسبه 11 بالمئه في عام 2020 اما
الانخفاض الاكبر فكان في البلدان متوسطه
ومنخفضه الدخل التقرير الاممي عزل الاسباب
الى انخفاض القدره على اكتشاف الضحايا
بالاضافه الى تقلص النشاط المهربين بسبب
قيود الجائحه الا ان الامم المتحده قالت
ان الحرف في اوكرانيا رفعت النسبه مجددا
كون الاتجار بالبشر ينتعش في مناطق الحروب
والازمات
الى زياد الان وموجز الخامسه الرياضي زياد
تفضل
[موسيقى]
نا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام اعلن نادي النصر
متصدر الدوري السعودي لكره القدم عن وصول
الحارس الارجنتينيه
لاجراء الفحص الطبي قبل اتنامي اجراءات
انتقاله للفريق رسميا حتى نهايه الموسم
الحالي وذلك خلفا للكولومبي
بوكا جونيورز الارجنتينيه
مناسبات هن عالميه كثيره شهدتها السعوديه
منذ بدايه العمل 2023 وبانتظار المزيد من
البطولات دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
من المنتظر ان يستبداء لاتحاد الاوروبي
لكره القدم ثغره التي مكنت نادي تشيلسي
الانجليزيه من توزيعه تكلفه انفاقه
القياسيه على الانتقالات لما يصل الى
ثماني سنوات بعد تلقي شكاوى من انديه اخرى
في الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز لكره القدم
وكشفت الصحافه البريطانيه السبت الماضي ان
عدد من منافس تشيلسي اتهموا النادي
بمحاوله خداع لوائح اللاعب المالي النظيف
حيث حدد قانون فيفا بالفعل خمس سنوات كحد
اقصى لمده العقد لكن للاستثناءات مسموح
بها ولا تستخدمها تشيلسي لتاجيل الكثير من
تكلفت انفاق الانتقال القياسيه البال 460
مليون جنيه استرليني منذ ان اشترى تدبو
للنادي في شهر يوليو الماضيه
عاد لعبه صديقاني ساديو ماني الى تدريبات
نادي بايرن ميونخ بطل المانيا لكره القدم
مع قرب تعافيه من اصابه حرمته من المشاركه
في بطوله كاس العالم الاخيره في قطر وسرح
المدرب فيوليان النيغلسمان في وقت سابق ان
اللاعب قد يعود في وقت بل في موعد ابكر من
المتوقع ما قد يجعله جاهزا لمواجهه باريس
سان جيرمان الفرنسي في الدور ثمن النهائي
لمسابقه دوري ابطال اوروبا لكره القدم
اعلن نادي ارسنال الانجليزيه عندما
المدافع الهولندي
بعقد طويل الاماد وبامكان اللاعب الشاب
اللاعب في مركز الدفاع اول الوسط وشارك في
فوار مع منتخب بلاده في كاس العالم
الماضيه وبحسب التقارير فانا صفقه ستكلف
وارسنال خاصه 22 مليون يورو مع الاضافه
في ختام الجوله 29 من الدوري الايطالي
لكره القدم يحل ميلان الليله ضيفا على
فريق غلاسيو وفشل حامل اللقب بتحقيق الفوز
في اخر اربع مباريات في جميع البطولات
ومنها الخساره امام الجار والغريبه
التقليديه الانتر بثلاثه اهداف نظيفه في
نهائي المسابقه كاس السوبر الايطاليه في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض ويملك فريق
المدرب فيولي 88 نقطه ومتاخرا بفارقه 12
نقطه على المتصدر نابولي بالمقابل يسعى
فريق لاسيو صاحب المرتبه السادسه للتقدم
الى المراكز الاربعاء الاولى في المسابقه
اهلا يا جاريث بيلا لاعب ونادي ريال مدريد
جالس وانا السابق ومنتخب ويلز والذي اعتزل
كره القدم واخرا انه سيبدا مسيرته
الاحترافيه في رياضه الجولف مطلع الشهر
القادم في بطوله اي تي ان تي ضمن الجوله
التي رابطه محترف اللعبه والتي ستقام في
ولايه كاليفورنيا الامريكيه بين الثاني
والخامس من شهر فبراير المقبل
كشف الرئيس البرازيلي لويس سيلفا خلال
زيارته الرسميه للعاصمه الارجنتينيه بيونس
ايرس انه يشجع للمره الاولى في حياتهم
المنتخب الارجنتين للفوز بكاس العالم وذلك
في المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك مع نظيره
الارجنتينيه البرتو فيرنانديز
[موسيقى]
2022 في وضع مميز ليس من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه بل ايضا من ناحيتي
كره القدم شخصيا شجعته للمره الاولى منتخب
الارجنتين واردته ان يصبح بطل
الفوز بالكاس العالم
ببطوله كاس العالم المقبله
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليكم ميسون
[موسيقى]
لهذا اليوم نلتقي غدا مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا